a
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
hello i'm ann hornaday the washington
post's
chief film critic welcome to washington
post live special welcome to our oscar
spotlight
series we're putting a spotlight on
the five films nominated for academy
awards for the best documentary feature
and today we're speaking about a
documentary from chile called
the mole agent and we're thrilled to be
joined by the film's director
mighty alverty and the film's producer
marcella santibanez welcome mighty and
marcella
thank you thank you it's great to see
both of you
what a charming film what a charming
protagonist
mighty um we got a little of the plot
there from
that teaser that uh the daughter
of a patron of a nursing home outside
wayne saudis i think or uh i don't know
where what city it's out of
yeah um
hires this private detective to check on
her mother
so when you set out to make this film
were you making your film about a spy or
were you making a film about
the elderly people
at the beginning i i was making a film
or i was development idea of a film
about private detective agencies like
how private detective agencies increase
in chile and how
ex-fbi have their own and
and it's start of thinking
why do the people hire private
detectives today
and from that starting point we see
different cases
and and we arrived to this case of the
retirement home that different
uh detectives have uh
in their in their agencies and
and that was a topic on all the cases
that we saw
that was a topic that it's really
related
with my previous film and and my own
obsession
so it was like the perfect match but it
started
the film with the idea to make a film
noise about a private detective
well that explains why you got you're
you're there
so early i mean one i don't want to
spoil anything about this movie but
but one of the most um amusing sequences
comes early where
the agency is auditioning all of these
different gentlemen to
to to go undercover and i was so curious
how you were able
to be there from the very beginning so
that that explains it
um so marcella as we see in the film
uh sergio our our hero your protagonist
is answering a want ad in the newspaper
so was that did he he did he know
you would be filming him going in was
that cl was that kind of part of his
assignment was agreeing to be
uh filmed by a documentary team
yeah i mean when he saw the ad in the
newspaper
it's the real ad for a job of to to
become a spy
when he arrived there he he met the
detective and he explained the whole
situation
and then we we came and told him so we
are also making a documentary would you
be
would you agree that we you know uh
shoot your whole experience and he
agreed
you know it's so interesting it's almost
meta because the
the detective agency is auditioning uh
they're casting you know they're there
it's almost like a casting call and then
you're casting
your film and you couldn't ask right for
a better
i i were your antennae up did you know
when you saw him like
what an amazing like he could carry a
film is that is that
clear from the very first few minutes
when you see someone like that
when i saw him the first time
yeah it was yeah we were very
disappointed because we were supposed to
work with
with the the mold that romula worked
with
but he broke his hip so he put that
to find a new one and when and when such
arrived yeah it was
love at first sight uh in the in the
sense that
all the months that arrived were
incredible because we're super active
people
at the 80s so i really admire all of
them when they arrive and
and for me all of them were were super
good
possible moles but sergio makes
something that was really special
he he start uh like
speaking about her feelings speaking
about his
to be a widower in his job interview
and for me that was something that it's
out
of of the common construction
or the way to be of old man's in
in chilean in latin america like we were
racist thinking that
men don't cry and all men neither
and or less so he started to be super
emotional and that was
like a super hard open person from the
beginning
and i think that that was also his mood
inside the
the retirement home all the time
absolutely he is a very special special
man
um and and because of
his character and the kind of person he
is the narrative really changes you know
you
you think you're going to be in on this
little caper film and it's a
and it is and it's got all those fun
spy scenes but then um sergio really
sort of transforms the place and i want
to show a clip
that gets to the sort of expresses how
important he becomes
to the mostly women who live there it's
mostly women and they just
have this really really profound
reaction to him
um because he's such a he's such a
compassionate man and he's such a good
listener so
let's play this clip and then i'll we'll
come back on the other side
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
so obviously that is when sergio is
being
crowned king of the nursing home um
so mighty i i guess would it be fair to
say that you would have had an entirely
different
film if if romulo had gone with a
different
gentleman for the mission yeah
probably uh if if i or if romero went
with his
uh mall of all of that he usually work
with it will be a film more focus
on the case and on the clues and on the
on the detective line and the narrative
will be more the trailer at the film
and know that film about experience and
about
what that people living there i think
that
yeah exactly he was the one that changed
the
focus of the film and the focus of the
narrative
yeah and marcella i understand
from our research that at one point
sergio wanted to leave
the project is is that true tell us a
little bit about that
yeah um i mean that was probably one of
the days i cried the most
during the shoot we we were
in the in the retirement home
and it was just at the beginning when he
just arrived and to be honest he was
having a hard time
uh i think for him was really impactful
to see all these people
and you know with the men shout or or
like he wasn't used to see people
so that felt so old and
i mean he he's older than most of the
people that actually appeared there but
he always seemed so young and for him
it was really tough at the beginning and
and he
had doubts and he said like i'm sorry i
think i'm gonna you know
uh leave this this research uh
and then we had to talk i mean his boss
talked to him and he said like
don't do it but then we also had to
explain him
er you know the importance of the film
also
but also i think he he just needed a
little bit
more of time to get used to the
situation and to start to fall in love
with all the people there and and
suddenly he he started making friends
and he started enjoying his time
there and i mean fortunately
he changed his mind
indeed i can i can understand though
that would have been
sort of overwhelming for him um
and mighty you've structured this film
in such a way that we
are we can forget that it's a
documentary just because it's so
dramatic and like you said it's
it's it does have that thriller element
but it's really a human drama
and there's a love you know there are
more than one love stories
partita falls in love but a lot of
people fall in love with sergio i think
the audience kind of falls in love with
sergio a little bit but
tell us a little bit i understand also
that you started filming in the home
before sergio got there is that right
yeah we started filming we we first
showed the training
of search inside the office and then we
went to shoot
the retirement home uh before that he
entered
like we we speak to them and we say that
we wanted to make
a documentary about old age and what
what people is living there
what people is happen what happened with
the people that it's living there
so that was our topic for them that it's
the topic of the film
like we didn't say the storytelling
about that the mole
but but we speak about the topic and so
we enter
before the people get used to us
we started to learn how to shoot
in that place and we spent like yeah
two or three weeks before uh said he
arrived so
all the residents were super used to us
we
we start to understand which one of them
feel comfortable with the camera
and when he arrived yeah he was one of
the
extra character that we were following
in that
in that space so we act that we we don't
know each other
uh when he enters
right so you were then able that that
makes sense so you weren't
it didn't look like you were necessarily
just following him
because you were filming everybody um
and then toward that end though were you
were you filming a variety of characters
and plot lines
in order to choose later what you want
how you wanted to structure it or was i
don't you know
you were getting so much material again
you're following
sergio but then you're you know there's
so many
other very compelling characters in this
film
um so i i'm not expressing this question
very well but i guess how
how sure of the storyline were you
at the time or did it come together in
the editing
no i think that at the editing or
we only were clear about the starting
point and the end
like this start with this
case but in the editing we were not
clear
about the focus probably or the
equilibrium between
the case and the and the life inside the
retirement home
and and we realized in the editing that
the importance was in search experience
and then the detective case was
only on a starting point to tell the
story
of this unique experience and
and yeah that is something that we
discover in the editing because in the
shooting as do you say we were
shooting different lines and we were
shooting a lot of characters
inside the retirement home more
characters
that indeed appears at the end of the
film we should uh
a lot of women's of that place that are
not in the
in the final cut but but we determinate
which were more important for sergio and
that it's the one that we maintain but
at the end it's because we take the
search point of view to take the story
so we construct
mostly the relationship that were super
important for him
yeah right um i'd like to set up another
clip and this this shows sergio in
action he's
he's when he gets his job romulo gives
him
special glasses i mean it's real james
bond
stuff and so this is a clip where he's
trailing his target a woman named marta
um or no i don't know that that's
that's another resident but uh marta has
sticky fingers
and she has a pen shop for going through
her neighbor's possessions let's take a
look at this clip and then we'll come
back
to
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
is
one of the great sources of comedy in
this film is watching
sergio and technology
interacting it's it's really it's really
charming
um but there's also kind of for me at
least there was
some an interesting subtext and this
might circle back marcella to his
misgivings at the beginning about you
know maybe wanting to pull out which is
the ethics of it you know i mean he's
he's sort of
deceiving people and then like you know
like might he said you're
even though yes you're making a film
about old age you weren't a hundred
percent transparent you know to to get
in you had to do a little
subterfuge so marcella could you
talk us through those issues the ethics
issues and the deception
yeah i mean um of course it's something
complicated and you think about it a lot
i feel that the reason why
why we went through and we kind of felt
right is because we knew that
at the end of the day what we were
portraying was the truth
inside that place and we knew that the
subject the real subject matter had to
do with old age
and with a giving you know
space and giving you know putting the
spotlight
in a a group of people that are usually
you know so on the side of society in a
way so
of course we had it was complicated
especially
in the retirement home not not telling
them about the the research but
in a way when we told them and they saw
the film their reaction was so
good and they were so happy with the
with the film
that we we knew that
in the core uh what we were doing was
was really
you know there was a big benefit and
and we knew that we were really making a
a
a piece of work that that would help i
don't know
i think that that was what what kept us
doing it i'm working on it and
you know but it's it is complicated of
course
mighty i don't would you want to add
anything i mean there's also even in
that scene we see
him photographing people's belongings i
mean there's a privacy issue
for him and then also for you i mean
it's very multi-layered so i don't know
if you have anything to add to that or
like how you
what your rules were for your own team
yeah i think that i we also have a
relief
in a sense that we feel that or i
feel that if something bad was happening
like
it was uh it was a denounce and it
supposed something bad was happening you
have a relief at the beginning because
you are
going to denounce something and and
that's move you
in another like ethical place when you
have to discover this kind of
of the announces like to how honest to
be to get the
the access but at marcella say like we i
feel
that we were super clear with the topic
or
or the film at the end it's the same
topic that we
we say at the beginning uh but we
also can take another road if the place
were not
good uh as it is so yeah we have
the the both possible roads at the
beginning but yeah i think that
they they knew that we were going to
shoot everything
and that we were looking there
and they were conscious about our camera
and not about sergio's camera yeah that
was
always a a big problem about
how he should and what are we going to
show about what he's shooting but
at the end he shoots so bad and he never
have like
nothing that uh it's
really private or something that our
camera cannot catch
so we feel super comfortable taking his
image too because
it was like a copy in some way of our
image but
from his lenses the small time
that he really cut something because he
he
never do it at the end
so so marcela did answer my question
which is have they have they seen it
have the women seen it
and uh she said yes could you tell us a
little bit more about their reactions to
the film
yeah the the women of the um of the
retirement home
when we we show it to them actually they
were the our first
first um viewers ever because it was
before our premiere ascendants actually
that we showed in the film
and we got together with might in the
post production house we invited them
and we said like okay the film is ready
but we need to tell you like a minor
detail
it's actually a spy movie and they're
like okay they were really nervous
and we say like but watch it and let's
talk afterwards and you'll see
and then yeah they were nervous at the
beginning but then once they saw the
film as i told you
they were really proud of the
because like i mean we told them we're
gonna show the good things and the bad
things that was something that we told
them regardless if this was about a spy
or not and they were always really open
so i think they were really nervous on
what
were we going to show but they felt
really proud because what the
film actually showed at the end is how
they really work and
and this place especially really really
cares
about their old people um there's this
uh cons like preconception in the world
that
that these places treat people badly
and that we should never you know take
our old
people there but they showed the other
way they say like we actually really
cared
and most of the times what we have to
deal is with
loneliness because it's it's the
families that kind of
leave us this responsibility and we have
to take over
and in that sense i feel they were
really
i don't know if happy is the word but at
least like proud
that what the world is seeing
is a reality that they they really are
and
that they want to keep on you know doing
it like that
absolutely i mean i think that's one of
the interesting um
transformations in the film are pivots
you know you
go like you said we come in with
assumptions
sergio and romulo come in with res
assumptions and then they are very
gradually and gracefully
um overturned and it's it's that's one
of the beautiful things that you do in
this film
um did they now so when they
saw the film was that when they realized
sergio was a spy or did that come
was that clear earlier did they find
that out earlier
no we decided to do it uh when we show
the film to them
we we thought that they suspect
and we really cannot believe that they
never suspect
and and when we show the film to them we
explain it before to show
it because we feel that when we realized
that it was a super good place
like if you explain it without
show the film today to them i think it
will be
super confusing so we we were thinking
to say to them
after the shooting but at the end we
thought
that our best card it will be to make
the explanation
with the result of the film like to them
to don't be
like afraid like so and i think that
it's work
like we explained it to them before to
to
show it and they yeah they laugh they
cry they
they love it and and it was a big relief
for us
that reception i am
sure and then you must tell us how
sergio how sergio doing what's he doing
what's he up to
sergio is i'm sorry you go
it's like a new chilean star he's
like receiving offers for ads
and and to be in tb yeah and to be ads
and and yeah he's like super like well
known
here the problem is like because of the
lockdown
he cannot go out enough so he
i think that he didn't really realize uh
how famous he is he make an instagram
and he has
like 30 000 followers
in two days and and now
he's going to the oscars and he told us
it's his first trip it's the first time
that he take a plane in his life
and he told that it's my first trip and
my
last adventure and he's so emotional
now with this that it's great
oh that's so charming well i think i
think
wherever he buys his sweaters i think
they should hire him to be
their spokes model because this man
has the most beautiful wardrobe i was
just
just fabulous really fabulous
you know you brought up the lockdown and
and um it was so
interesting to me that as you said this
film premiered at sundance but then
the world changed and our lives changed
and the context changed and
i don't know both marcelo and then
mighty i'd love to hear from you
if you think the meaning of the film has
changed for audiences because it is so
much about loneliness and isolation
but also fellowship and communion i
don't know
um do you think it sort of changed its
own morphed a little bit
in the during the pandemic i'll start
with marcela
um yes of course i mean it's not
like it's it's weird to say like
old age is uh trendy now you know
because
the old age is something that has always
been there
but it's just like the pandemic and the
lockdown
has taught us how difficult it is to
live in isolation
and uh it's it has been you know so
contingent like we are all talking about
isolation
and this film shows you that that these
people have been isolated their whole
lives you know we just realized because
we were living it in
you know first uh like we are we are
experiencing it
but but these people have experienced
that their whole life and also
on the other side and i feel like the
pandemic has
made us be much more like
honest or more emotional and we
we have suffered like worldwide so we
are also
more open to talk about our emotions
and i think this film also gives you
that chance
it's really impactful to read for
example on social media
how everybody talks how they cried with
this film
how they call their parents and i feel
like in a normal year
maybe a society we wouldn't be so open
to talk
about our feelings and and i think that
in that sense
uh yeah the complicated year that we had
to premiere
film really really made a huge influence
in the impact that the film
is hiding is having a i would say
worldwide
so true mighty do you want to add
anything that's very well said
yeah it's very well
oh well and now we're out of time but i
can't thank you both enough heidi and
marcella thank you so much for joining
us and congratulations
on this honor thank you very much